I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will first we'll be ready hey
youtubers new Game of Thrones come in
tonight so we need to talk about Jon
Snow and Dragons we've been saying
winter is coming for so many seasons now
we should really say fan services coming
Jon Snow Daenerys meeting tonight for
the first time Jon Snow doesn't have
ghosts with him which is a whole other
thing I'll link that video at the end of
this but as we know that Jon Snow is a
dragon Stone regardless of what your
interpretation of the prophecy of the
prince who was promised was he's
critical to it the new idea is that
people shouldn't be quite as specific
with it if they have been in the past
like the prince was promised is no one
person there are promise people and
there's the three heads of the Dragon
which is also part of the prince who was
promised so when people first read that
in the books they thought that meant
there were three promised dragon riders
there are a number of hopefuls in the
books and as the TV show has slowly
changed things from that and now we have
Melisandre saying prophecy is a tricky
thing maybe we should be careful about
how we interpret that the idea that
everybody has interpreted every vision
everything wrong on the TV show even
brand hasn't got everything a hundred
percent but there's this theory that Jon
Snow being half Targaryen being part of
this huge prophecy being so critical to
the story is one of the dragon riders
which dragon should he ride and how long
before the show pays that off it's only
just revealed Jon Snow's true heritage
and it hasn't even officially on-screen
confirmed that he's half Targaryen
though if you've read the books you've
read between the lines all the clues the
show's given you about Rhaegar Targaryen
Lyanna stark you know that his father is
Rhaegar so there's this big thing going
on in the TV show where they're trying
to pay off all these loose threads that
they set up there are a lot of people
that think that's even the only reason
that they're bringing Gendry back just
so that they don't leave that plot
thread hanging and he won't have some
larger role to play but when you talk
about Jon Snow riding dragons you have
to take into consideration how the
Valyrian bonded with their dragons how
they tame them so to speak it's not
quite the same thing as taming animals
and then there's the consequences of Jon
Snow riding a dragon I don't think
there's any way that he rides a dragon
this season I do feel like if they're
going to pay that off it won't be till
season 8 because think about the way the
Lords of the North reacted to Jon Snow
when he merely
just the idea of them meeting with
daenerys targaryen cannot be trusted
which is a bit of an eye wink to the
fact that John Stowe is also part
Targaryen which means that Littlefinger
is probably doing the calculus right now
even if he's not a hundred percent sure
that John Snow is the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen he probably has his suspicions
so this season seems like it's more
about bringing John Snow to dragons and
then leaving what happens next for
season eight hopefully we can all be in
agreement that if Jon Snow is going to
write a dragon the dragon he should ride
should be the one that's named for his
father regal so hopefully regal will
survive the season eight and they can
pay that off but typically in the past
the way the Targaryen past dragons now
because they live much longer than
humans do is that classically they'll
start the bonding process between person
and dragon when the dragon is still in
the egg unhatched so they'll put dragon
eggs in children's beds hoping to form a
bond between them then you have
situations like balerion the black dread
a dragon who was hatched in ancient
Valyria before the doom he was taken to
Dragonstone when the Targaryens escaped
with their family most of the stories
you hear about them are from Aegon's
conquest him riding around the Seven
Kingdoms lighting everybody on fire by
the time of the conquest Valyrian was
over a hundred years old
meaning that he had multiple riders and
for the most part people just assumed
that as long as your Targaryen you can
ride your ancestors dragon so if Aegon
the conquerer had children they'd be
able to ride bully Dorian just like bol
Aryans form a rider pass them down to
Aegon the conquerer but it's actually
not quite so simple there's a little bit
of a clarification during the princess
in the Queen's story whereby you find
out that even if you're the child or
you're part of the bloodline of a dragon
rider you can't just automatically hop
that dragon and everything will be fine
you have to bond with it the same way
that someone like Jon Snow bonds with
ghost it sounds kind of magical and
supernatural but it's actually much more
practical like it happens in real life
all the time like people bond with
horses you have to get a horse to trust
you before it'll let you ride it dragons
are just the uber version of that so
just because you can ride a horse
doesn't mean that your child could come
along and just hop on the horse there's
even a special
passage in the princess and the Queen's
story where it implies that someone who
was not a Targaryen was able to tame a
dragon called sheep's dealer so it reads
in the end the brown dragon was brought
to heel by the cunning and persistence
of a small brown girl it doesn't really
give her name of six and ten named Neddy
who delivered him a freshly slaughtered
sheep every morning until sheeps dealer
learned to accept and expect her she was
black-haired brown-eyed brown skinned
skinny foul-mouthed filthy and fearless
in the first and last Dragon Rider of
the Dragon sheeps dealer so it just
implies that you can win dragons over
given enough time and persistence you
get them to trust you they'll let you
ride them in just because you're a
Targaryen doesn't mean they will
automatically trust you I really love
the way it talks about the qualities
that girl the implication being that as
long as Jon Snow shows no fear and gets
one of the dragons to trust him somehow
he will be able to ride it whether or
not he wants to or whether or not the
realm will riot if he does so hopefully
that explains a little bit about how the
show is treating the three heads of the
Dragon prophecy how Jon Snow being part
Targaryen makes it much more likely that
he's able to write a dragon but also how
that doesn't necessarily matter a
hundred percent there are other ways to
ride dragons like it would probably take
many many months to win a dragon over
just bringing it dead sheep every single
day but you can imagine dragon would
probably like someone more if they
brought him a fresh sheep every single
day but also just to address tyrion
dragon rider i know a lot of people are
thinking tyrion may be part Targaryen
maybe there are some clues and what
happened during season six yes i do
think that tyrion should write a dragon
i do think that they trust him so i do
think that if he tried he'd be able to
do it whether or not the show ever tries
to pay that off it seems like this
season is more about Jon Snow coming to
Daenerys so it's choosing more to focus
on Jon Snow in this grand prophecy sense
but it does feel like they're going to
wait til season eight to pay a lot of
these big things off because he's only
leading Daenerys for the first time this
season so let me know in the comments
who is going to be the first person to
write a dragon besides De Niro
do you think they'll pay that Jon Snow
twist off in season eight and which
dragon do you want to see him ride but
what will happen tonight is I'll post my
episode 3 video after it airs and then
I'll post my Rick and Morty episode 2
video early Monday morning then I'll
post that Game of Thrones episode 4
trailer video so Rinka Morty is back if
you guys didn't know it's going to be on
at 11:30 p.m. tonight after Game of
Thrones so I recommend you check it out
if you've never seen it before it's on
Adult Swim congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Lewis please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
the trailer for tonight's episode and
you can click here for brand new Rick
and Morty thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight